you can smelled it so you could I could
walk into a place and I know there's a
corpse in it hi my name is Angela
Gilmore Manning I'm gene dahlias from
Royale Gilmore's funeral home and hope
today I've answered a few questions that
you had weird unclaimed bodies normally
the city will take possession we possess
the body in other words if they homeless
they'll go to the extent where they will
try to get in touch with a family member
or so if not you go to potter's field
potter's field is the general cemetery
for homeless folks that's what they call
city burial to prepare body is to
preserve the body that's through the
process of embalming the embalming
process is just like you're performing
surgery and based on the way you
approach it you have to know what the
person died from so you know how to
preserve the body so what we're doing is
we're using the carotid artery to inject
fluid to preserve the tissue the body
tissue and as we're doing that
simultaneously we're draining through
the carotid vein the only time you smell
something would be once the body's been
there for a few days and once you die
you undergo certain chemical changes on
the inside will which will reflect on
your physical appearance that's when you
start deteriorating and then there you
will have an order the way we deal with
smell is when you're in the prep room
you have to be equipped put on your mask
and mask they have filters where you
don't get the odor that's emanating from
the body and to add to that once the
body is embalmed
there is no order as you know an autopsy
is a process where they sample every
organ in the body and then when the body
arrives at the funeral home we have to
put the person back together and the
organs are placed back into the body
[Music]
we're not actually doing the cremation
here on the premises we have to go to a
Crematory in order to cremate the body
not all funeral services have open
caskets it's really designed to have a
viewing for the family they do that
because it's traditional for some
families not all families some families
choose to have closed caskets techniques
and then they have equipment such as a
lift you could use a lift with straps I
would caution anyone again you don't try
to lift dead weight okay you use certain
techniques to move bodies around and
that's why they they have lifts you
could use the lifts to navigate inside
the prep room and to place bodies where
you want them to be
our death certificates are obtained
through the doctor when someone passes
either at home or hospital or nursing
home the original death certificate is
signed by a doctor and once we receive
that signature then we're able to claim
the body
[Music]
well my father told me years ago that
funeral homes would design like homes
because there were homes for the dead
years ago when families had loved ones
to pass on they used to repose in their
homes initially well actually they don't
only on the exterior of the building not
on the inside and the inside is just
like everyone's go to bed and go to
sleep so the lights off but and the
exterior of the building to see the
entity yes the lights happen to be love
of working and also knowing that I'm out
here helping a family how I keep my
spirits lifted knowing that I'm here to
assist families in making funeral
arrangements for their loved one with
dignity and honor
[Music]